Oh
all right welcome to introduction to
game development
my name is David Malin and this is
Colton Ogden and this is a class that
assumes only a class like cs50 which is
the colleges in the extension schools
introduction to computer science but
more generally we just assume that you
have prior programming experience in
most any language and therefore have
some comfort with some of the basic
constructs of programming but we assume
no background in Lua or love 2d or any
of the frameworks that we'll be using in
the class all of that lies ahead so if
you're like me you probably grew up with
video games of some sort and when you
maybe started programming the
programming environments were perhaps
very text-based black and white terminal
window and the like and maybe you did
something graphical with a language like
scratch or Alice or beyond or if you're
in the world of the web you've made more
graphical applications of some sort but
still pretty static the sort of content
comes on the screen then the content
changes and so forth and it's a little
less obvious if you're a little newer to
programming how you go about creating
some of those games from yesteryear with
which you all grew up where there's a
lot more animation there's a lot more
asynchronicity lots of things happening
at the same time a lot of events
happening and you all not only want to
capture this interactivity but also want
to respond to events that are happening
especially if you have players elsewhere
next to you or online and so the way the
course will be structured is through a
narrative of these various games many of
which you might have played yourself but
over the course of the semester will we
dive into the context of each of these
games and look at some of the underlying
principles the constructs via which they
were built up and really use them as a
point of departure for talking about
those various capabilities that you
might integrate into your own games and
then punctuating the semester ultimately
will be a number of milestones some in
the form of smaller assignments that are
meant to reinforce just some of the more
recent material and sort of set you up
for success with the courses a deeper
and more hands-on projects because
indeed the project is where you'll build
or extend some of your own games and
then the class itself will culminate at
the very end of the semester with your
very own final project an opportunity to
propose and design and implement a game
that somehow or other draws upon the
courses lessons so that when you walk
out of here in just a few months time
you've not only played your fair share
of games but have actually built several
of your own so without further ado allow
me to turn things over to Colton
for a look and a stroll through
yesteryears pong
I'm very excited to begin teaching you
guys this course because game
development was actually what got me
into programming in the first place I
remember back in 2006 or 2007 buying
this book here 3d game programming
all-in-one which was a look through 3d
game programming and it was a monolithic
text in the context of a game engine
that was popular in the late 2000s
called torque it's not as in vogue these
days but it at the time was pretty
popular and it used a language called
torque script and I remember reading
through this book and seeing all this
code and I had never seen like source
code at all before or had ever been
introduced to programming and frankly I
found it quite intimidating because I
was looking at all this syntax that I
didn't understand and I didn't know
anything about game development I had
always played games growing up and been
fascinated by it
but as I started getting more
comfortable with computers and I started
to get more curious about it and
realized that it was a major profession
I started to dive a little deeper this
was my first foray and after spending a
little bit of time away from it after
looking through the the source code for
a torque ship which was rather arcane a
lot of % symbols and dollar signs of the
weird things that I just hadn't gotten
my mind around I went back to it started
to really learn the basics of
programming and other languages like
Python and C and C++ and I grew to
really like programming and computer
science a lot and here's just an image
of what torque looked like at the time
which is really the sort of predecessor
to unity nowadays although in my opinion
unity does things a lot better it was
more accessible it uses languages that
are more in vogue and popular and used
by other people already in other domains
and so we'll be covering unity at the
tail end of the course and we'll be
covering predominantly 2d game
development but the topics that we'll be
covering today as we get started in the
context of pong are these bullet points
here luluwa which will be the language
that we're using predominantly
throughout the course which is a dynamic
scripting language very similar to
Python and JavaScript will be covering
love 2d as a primary game framework
which is a
runtime and a framework which exposes
all of its methods for drawing audio
input etc via Lua so that it's very easy
to write code very quickly but get very
good results and the documentation for
their for their framework is superb in
my opinion today we'll be talking about
a few just basic principles as we get
our feet wet with game development
things like drawing shapes drawing text
these are both very big aspects of pong
which is just a very simple game based
on shapes and text moving around the
screen we'll be talking about Delta time
and velocity which Delta time is
probably arguably one of the most
important variables that we keep track
of in any game framework or engine which
is just the amount of time that's
elapsed since the last frame of
execution in our game measured in left
2d in terms of seconds fractions of
seconds I'll be talking about game state
because you can have a state in your
game you can be at the title screen you
can be playing you can be in a menu this
will obviously be very important because
you want different update logic and
rendering logic depending on what state
you're in I'll be talking about basic
object-oriented programming for those
who might be unfamiliar coming from C
it's basically a way of encapsulating
our data any of our game objects in such
a way that the variables that are
relevant to them are put together along
with functions that will operate on that
data so instead of having like 20
different variables for all these
different objects that you have to keep
track of in your code each individual
object can keep track of all its own
information like its position or
anything else that's relevant to it I'll
be talking about hitboxes today
predominantly in the context of box
collision because we'll be talking about
pong which is just paddles and a ball
those are all rectangles and they'll be
colliding with what's called access
aligned bound access aligned bounding
boxes which makes calculating whether
two boxes collided very simple as
opposed to calculating rotated hit boxes
which is a bit more complicated and then
lastly we'll polish off with sound
effects because adding that polished
layer in my opinion is important and it
ties it all together it makes it feel
like a more cohesive whole so two
important things that we'll need to do
when we're following along with the
examples which I'll show you a link to
the repo in a moment is getting love 2d
installed it's a very simple process the
first link here is just a
download link so it's available for all
major operating systems so Linux Mac and
Windows and then the getting started
link down here below will give you some
tips as to how to get started actually
running it on your machine on Mac ia
leus the actual runtime executable
within the app that it comes with so in
my bash profile so that I can easily
just type love space dot in any
directory that has a main Lua file and
it can run it anywhere very simply and
there are similar instructions located
on the page for other operating systems
and this is the repo here which has all
of the source code that we'll be using
today and I've structured it in a series
of 13 different sub repos so that you
can follow along and we can build upon
pong starting from scratch going all the
way to a fully implemented game so the
first thing we'll talk about is what Lua
is will be using Lua for about 75% of
the course it's a very popular dynamic
scripting language Portuguese for moon
and it was invented in the early 90s as
primarily a config language and a
runtime language for compiled code bases
to save time on adding code to those
code bases and recompiling them a lot
faster and a lot easier especially in
the context of the 90s when computers
were much slower to expose the core
functionality of your application and to
Lua so that you can just run it
dynamically and then interact with your
compiled code on the fly rather than
having to recompile and wait minutes
potentially hours just to get some new
behavior it's a language that's focused
around the concept of a table almost
everything in Lua aside from basic
variables are tables a table is
essentially a dictionary in Python or an
object in JavaScript very similar
intended for embedded use in larger
applications and the the the very nature
of Lua intended to be used in the
context of these large applications
meant that it was perfect for
interacting with game engines because
game engines are a perfect example of
code bases that are traditionally
compiled code for speed purposes but it
can be very cumbersome to have to add
minor functionality and then recompile
it and potentially have your whole
studio take hours so we'll be using Lua
and a compiled game framework
Toodee to allow us to rapidly develop
it's similar to JavaScript and Python a
little bit more so to JavaScript and
it's very excellent because it was
initially intended as a config language
and a just sort of a glue layer it's
very good for storing data and code
together almost one in the same soul of
2d is a fast 2d game development
framework it's compiled in C++ and it
runs very efficiently because it's so
simple despite the fact that we're
running it in Lua and as modules for
basically anything you would need in the
context of 2d game development only 2d
game development officially although
some people I know are working on slight
little 3d experiments but nothing
official yet but it has graphics
keyboard input math basically anything
you could want in the context of 2d game
development it's completely free it's
portable you can even run it on mobile
and also the web and it's excellent for
prototyping even if you don't
necessarily want to publish a game in
love 2d it's great and easy and fast
just to whip something up in love to D
and then port that over to whatever
framework or engine you might be using
in the real world so before we get into
looking at some actual concrete code the
I think the most fundamental thing we
should take a look at is what a game
loop is so a game fundamentally is just
an infinite loop like a while true or a
while one only in this case every
iteration of that loop we're doing a set
of steps back to back over and over
again we're processing input so we're
seeing has the user press the key on the
keyboard have they touched their
joystick have they moved the mouse click
the mouse if they have we need to feed
that into our update we need to keep
track of that and then change anything
in our game state that relies upon that
input so we should move our paddles we
should detect collision we should
register all of this and then whatever
has updated we want to re-render that we
want to render it render where it's
changed so that we have the we we see on
our screen visually that things have
actually changed in our game world and
we interact with it and we get a sense
that where we're using something
interacting with something dynamic
and in the context of 2d games the most
fundamental way of looking at the world
is via the 2d coordinate system which is
just simply as we learned in geometry in
high school
X and y axis in this case it's slightly
different than what we typically learn
in high school we tend to learn that the
Y XY origins sort of bottom left Y
positive goes up negative goes down
positive X goes right and negative X
goes left but in this case we're
actually starting in the top left and
then it goes Y positive down Y negative
up X positive right x negative left and
everything that we want to draw in our
game needs to have an x and y coordinate
to draw in order for it to be visually
seen on the screen so today's goal we're
gonna start a fairly low level and work
our way up through examples today and in
future classes our first game is
arguably one of the simplest but also
one of the most famous games of all time
pong which was released in 1972 and the
gist of pong is you have a paddle on the
left side of the screen a paddle on the
right side of the screen whoever scores
10 points by getting the ball past their
opponent's paddle onto the edge of the
screen wins and so today in our lecture
the scope is we want to first and
foremost draw shapes to the screen
because that's how we get our ball and
ball and paddles rendering and those are
just simply rectangles we want to
control the 2d position of these paddles
because we want them to move up and down
and want the ball to also move we want
to detect collision between the paddles
and the ball because that's how we get
the ball to deflect off the paddles and
to deflect off the ceiling and the floor
and also how we detect whether it's gone
and beyond to the edges of the screen
such that one player scores a point and
then we want to add sound effects for
sort of a feedback and sort of put
ourselves into the game a little bit
more and then score keeping because
ultimately the purpose of the game is to
beat your opponent so we want a way to
see who scored ten points first and so
we're going to look through a set of
examples now in the repo if we look at
pong zero I've set this to be called the
the day zero update it's a trend among
many games to have the game's release
major content updates
the X updates oh just to be cute I think
we'll call each individual example here
the something update and so I'm gonna go
into the pong zero repo of the directory
that github repo and if we're looking at
pong zero here we can see it says here
the day zero update I've commented
everything fairly heavily so that we can
if you're reading the code you can sort
of get a sense of what's going on at
line 23 we're going to start off by just
declaring a window width and a window
height and these are just constant
variables that'll be accessible
throughout the rest of our application
so I'm just setting 1280 by 720 as an
arbitrary resolution it doesn't matter
too much an important thing that we need
to look at here is at line 29 we're
using a function called love load and
I'm actually gonna go back to the slides
here we're gonna look at a few functions
and I'm gonna go over them and just sort
of tell you what they do before we look
at the code in too much detail so love
dot load is just a function that given
to us by love left to D and we override
it we give it behavior we tell it what
to do and love to D is going to look at
it in our main lua file if we're looking
at pong zero you'll see it just has a
main lua file love to de expects just a
main dot lua file and we'll run the main
dot lua file and you can reference any
other file within the directory from
that main.lua file it's our bootstrap
effectively we are going to override
love dot load with whatever we want to
execute at the very beginning of our
application it's just a start up
function we could also define all that
behavior outside of the function above
it but it's good practice to find it
within love dot load so that someone
reading your code will know okay this is
where all the startup code takes place
love update DT is a very important
function this function takes in a
variable called DT love passes it in a
function you're going to override it
with your own behavior and love is going
to execute this every frame passing it
in Delta time and you can use Delta time
DT in that function to change your
application
based upon how much time has passed DT
will always be a fraction of a second
potentially more depending on how slow
your computer is but typically one
sixtieth of a second and you can scale
anything in your game by that amount to
get even behavior across all frame rates
love draw is the other big function
amongst between update and draw two of
the two arguably most important
functions love draw is the function that
we're going to define that has all of
our drawing behavior our rendering
behavior in it and that's where we can
draw our paddles we can draw our ball
and an update is where we can like
change the paddles position and so forth
to more important functions we'll take a
look at in the first example love
graphic stop printf is the love 2d
analog of printf and see the difference
being that this printf lets us actually
draw physically on to the screen versus
a console we give it a text as a string
and an x and a y-coordinate and
optionally a width and in a line and
it'll draw the text at X Y but it'll
also take into consideration the width
and it'll also take in consideration be
aligned the width is how much to align
it and the align is the mode of
alignment so if we say X 0 with our
window width and then we say align
Center is going to go between 0 and our
window width and Center align it so
that'll have the effect of Center
aligning our text but we can just as
easily say right and it'll right align
it between those two and have the effect
of rendering the screen during the text
along the right edge of the screen and
then lastly love window set mode takes a
width and a height and some optional
parameters those parameters being things
like vsync and fullscreen and will
actually set up our window and get it
rendering on to the screen and so if we
go back to our source code here at line
29 we're overriding love load we're
passing in love dot window dot set mode
window width and window height which
recall we defined up above as 1280 by
720 we're passing in a table this is the
syntax for a table these curly brackets
and the way that we defined keys and
values is just with an equal sign
they're in so full screen gets false
resizable gets false vsync
it's true so it's going to not be full
screen it's going to be resizable but it
is gonna be synced to our monitors
refresh rate and that's what vsync is
short for a vertical sync and then on
line 40 we're overriding love draw and
this has the loved graphic stuff printf
function therein and we're saying we're
passing in the string hello pong we're
starting it at x0 we're setting it at Y
window height divided by 2 minus 6
because the default font size in love 2d
is 12 pixels tall so we're shifting it
up by 6 so it's perfectly centered
vertically in the screen and then we're
setting the alignment amount the width
to window width so that it's gonna align
it within the entire width of our window
and then we're setting it to center
alignment so it's gonna be Center
aligned within our entire window
starting at x0 and so if we go to pawn 0
and then we actually run it as the
effect of doing this we're just
rendering in our default font default
size
hello pong right in the middle of the
screen so I'm not a terribly exciting
example but it is it is showcasing the
most important functions of love 2d so
that we can get started with slightly
more interesting examples so our first
content update is the low res update so
we're developing pong and pong is an old
game it doesn't look like the example
that we just looked at where the you
know the font is fairly high res we want
something that looks a little more retro
so what we want to do is get our
resolution looking like it's from a game
released in 1972 so what we're gonna do
is look at a few more important
functions here so pong one has these
functions so love graphics dot set
default filter this function the purpose
of that is every time we have a font or
an image in our application it's going
to be applied a filter by default so
it's going to by default a bilinear
filter so it's going to happen the
effect of that is basically whenever we
magnify or downscale a texture it's
going to think that it's going to assume
that we want it to be slightly blurred
so as to not look too pixelated which is
good in
in context for higher res 2-d game
development that's good but as we're
gonna see that's not particularly good
in the context of retro games retro
games have have a very 2d crisp
pixelated aesthetic and we want to
preserve that and so this lets us set a
default filter will see that in usage
shortly another important very important
function which is the input phase of our
game loop that we saw earlier loved key
pressed key is what's going to allow us
to start interacting with that aspect of
our game so lab key pressed key is a
callback function that love expects in
main Lua
we're gonna override it it gets passed
in a key and this function gets called
every time by love 2d whenever we press
a key it'll detect a key pressed and
it'll call this function whatever we've
defined in here it'll call it and we can
set it to take in certain keys and
perform certain operations on that input
and it'll get a string so if we say if
we press the Escape key key is going to
be equal to the string escape in that
function and we have access to that and
another important function loved event
quit this has just the very simple
effect of quitting the application
though we can call it in the code as
opposed to doing it ourselves and so
here's an example of what texture
filtering looks like point filtering is
the same as nearest-neighbor filtering
which is what we're going to be using
bilinear filtering is shown on the right
where it looks pretty blurry that's what
love 2d applies by default to both fonts
and to textures and we'll see that in an
example I can actually run it in two
different styles so if you go to pong
one in the repo and then we run it we
see here
hello pong is now blown up and we'll
look at some more code actually to see
as to why it's blown up but if we go
back to our code let me pull up pong one
go to main.lua and then I'm going to
explain this in just a second but let me
comment this out and we'll see the
difference here you can see it looks a
lot blurrier and that's the default
texture filtering taking place it
applies like I said not only to textures
but also to fonts and that's not the
aesthetic we want so let's look at pong
one in detail starting at the top on
line 28 we're requiring a library this
is how you get a library in your loved
2d application or your love application
just equals require in the name of the
library pushes we're going to be using
to take our 1280 by 720 window and turn
it into a virtual resolution window at
432 by 243 we can start to think of our
game in terms of a more low res feel and
think about it in for 32 by 243 pixels
but still render it in a window that's
arbitrarily sized in this case we're
preserving the 1280 by 720 window that
we saw before if you go to our loved odd
function we see this being used on line
47 instead of love window set mode we're
now using push setup screen the push
libraries setup screen function where it
takes a virtual with a virtual height
our regular window width and our window
height and then the same table as before
and this has the effect of setting up a
window that's got our concrete
dimensions of 1280 by 720 but a virtual
resolution of 432 by 243 and so now when
it renders as we'll see shortly it's
good well as we already did see actually
it's a magnified it has the effect of
giving us a lower resolution and Enlai
on line 58 if we look at the love key
pressed function we've put in there if
the key equals it's the string escape
then love dot event quit so now we have
input handling we've overridden love key
pressed key which love 2d is going to
look for in our application and then
call as needed and then we're just
looking in there if the key is escape
then love dot event quit and if I run
the application
I can now press escape on my keyboard
and just quit it and not have to
command quit or click the X on a Windows
application and we've changed one more
thing also in the Love draw function on
line 70 we're using the push library now
we need to it functions sort of as a
state machine and that we set it to
start rendering at a virtual resolution
with push apply start and then push
apply end and then anything in between
this is very similar actually to how
opengl works we won't go into too much
detail but this is very similar and
spirit to how much of OpenGL programming
works push apply start push apply end
between that whatever we call is going
to render at this virtual resolution and
so we're calling the same love dog
graphics type printf function
hello pong zero virtual height divided
by two minus six same parameters and it
has the effect of rendering everything
that's still got the old aliasing going
on the sky texture filtering going on
has the effect of giving us our
magnified text so same text same size
but now our window of rendering is much
smaller so any questions so far on how
any of this works okay awesome
so we've gotten text writing to the
screen but we're nowhere close to pong
yet so the first big thing I think
that's going to get us close to that
direct in that direction is what we're
gonna call the rectangle update so some
important functions that we should look
at love dog graphics that new font the
default font I believe is Arial
we don't want Arial in our application
because we want something that looks a
little more retro we want something that
looks more relevant loved out graphics
dot new font will basically take a path
to a font file that we have in our
folder which if we're in the pong to
folder you'll see a font TTF file and a
size because every font object that we
instantiate needs to have a size because
the font objects are immutable once
constructed they cannot be changed so
they need to be allocated on a size by
size basis
love dog graphics not set font will take
whatever font object we've acquired from
this function call and we can set it
here and it'll set the active font in
love 2d to be that font love is a state
machine in the same sense as before in
that it'll have an active font at any
one time and whatever print functions
you call will use the currently active
font and also applies to whatever color
you might want to render to the screen
whatever if you have a font and you want
to maybe render it in red you need to
set love to these active color to red as
well love dog graphic stock clear is a
function that takes an RGB a quadruple
and will flush the screen in that color
it just has a simple effect of wiping
the screen in that color useful for
drawing just flat colored backgrounds
and then the last function probably the
most important function is love graphics
dot rectangle and this is the first
function that we'll see that actually
end up drawing something beyond text to
the screen it takes a a mode which can
be fill or line an x and a y and a width
and a height and it'll draw a rectangle
in that mode so either filled so a
filled rectangle or a line rectangle
it'll take it'll draw it at X Y with the
width and a height that we pass in so
let's go ahead and take a look at pong
to where we can see this actually
implemented so pong - we have our font
TTFN in there that i've included and
then a main.lua and by the way I forgot
to mention last example push the library
that we required is also just in the
same directory and you can just do
require as long as the file is there
within the directory
it'll just load it you don't you don't
have to specify dalawa it assumes when
you require some string that it follows
with a dot Lewis suffix so here looking
at main.lua in pong - the rectangle
update so on line 28 through 30 4 it's
all the same stuff we're requiring push
we have our width and height virtually
and physically in our love load function
we are on line 43 declaring small font
to be a low fat graphics new font giving
it the path font TTFN because it's right
there in the same directory at size
eight and this is going to create a font
object small font that we can then set
as the active font as needed so if we go
down to line 78 in the same directory we
see we're calling love graphics clear
and so we're passing it in a color I
sampled some images of pong on Google
Images and saw background gray that I
liked so 40 45 52 RGB and then 255 just
means completely opaque so no
transparency the Alpha component and
then we're doing the same printf
function as you did before on line 81
below that on line 89 down through 95
we're actually calling love graphics dot
rectangle and these are drawing the two
paddles and then the ball so note love
duck graphics dot rectangle fill mode
because we want the the paddles to be
completely filled as is the ball we're
giving it an XY of 10:30 and a width
height of 520 and on 992 we're and
that'll have the effect of drawing it a
little bit shifted from the top-left
corner 5 pixels wide 20 pixels tall on
line 92 we're doing the same thing
except we're going virtual width minus
10 so it's going to go to the right edge
of our screen virtual width minus 10 so
432 minus 10 so for 22 and then virtual
height minus 50 so it's gonna be
slightly it's gonna be slightly up from
the bottom of the screen so we have our
top left paddle and our bottom right
paddle and then the ball is dead center
so we're setting a of doing another
graphics a rectangle call virtual with
-2 divided by 2 so right in the middle -
2 because our our ball is gonna be 2
pixels wide by 2 pixels tall and same
thing with virtual height - to our
virtual height divided by 2 - 2 so I'm
going to go ahead and CD into the pong -
directory and run it and that has the
effect of we have our new font here in
the middle so it looks nice and retro
much more so than the Arial font as
before we have a rectangle here 5 pixels
wide by 20 pixels tall a ball in the
middle which is 4 pixels wide by 4
pixels tall and then a paddle in the
bottom right which is same dimensions as
the paddle
on the left so it looks very similar to
pong it's not interactive at all but we
sort of getting the feel of what we want
our application to look like we have it
mostly sketched out so any questions so
far on as to how this works okay awesome
so pong 3 so currently we have no
interactivity with our application and
we want to be able to move the paddles
around we don't want to just be looking
at it at an image the whole time so the
paddle updates gonna solve this problem
for us we're gonna actually get our
first sort of beyond pressing escape to
quit the application we're going to get
a sense of interacting with it
dynamically so the important function
that we're gonna look at in this example
is love dot keyboard dot is down some
key and this is a true this is a boolean
function it just returns true or false
depending on whether the key that we
pass in as a string is currently press
down on this frame so it just returns
true or false and so let's go ahead and
take a look at the demo we're gonna go
ahead and pull up pong three the main
lua they're in notice that line 37 if
you're looking in pong 3 we have a new
constant we've defined called paddle
speed which gets the value 200 and this
is just an arbitrary value that I found
was a good speed but this is how fast
our paddle is gonna move we're gonna
scale it by Delta time so we're gonna
multiply it by how many seconds have
passed
typically a fraction of a second since
the last frame and this is going to
therefore move the same distance over
time depending on whether your
computer's running at ten frames per
second or sixty frames per second so if
we go down here to line 63 I've also set
up two new variables player one scorer
and player to score those are both
initialized at zero we're gonna add in
this example also some rendering of the
score and notice here on line 49 I've
also added a new font which showcases
how you need to separate fonts based on
their size because they're immutable
objects score font gets loved up
graphics new font same exact font file
but it's 32 pixels large because the
font are the score when rendered in pong
is pretty large in the middle of the
screen
and so we're creating we have two
different fonts now one for rendering
our message one for rendering our score
and it's just gonna render these two
variables player one scorer and player
to score and then we've also initialized
our Y values for the rectangles the
paddles on the left on the right we need
to keep track of their Y position
because paddles and pong can only move
up or down so player one Y gets the same
value we did before when we initialize
the rectangle when we drew it on to the
screen it's gonna start at Y 30 so
pretty high up and player two Y is gonna
start pretty low virtual height minus 50
which is 432 minus 50 and so in love
update which is our first actual use of
the update function on line 75 with the
DT parameter that gets passed in note
remember that love 2d we'll pass that in
for us but we need to give it we need to
define the behavior inside of it we're
using love keyboard is down and we're
passing in the string W and s for this
first block this first block here is
player ones movement so traditionally on
computer WASD is to move and this
example we're going to allow ourselves
to move both paddles so we're gonna use
W and s for the left paddle and up or
down for the right paddle so if love
duck keyboard that is down W which means
R we've currently pressing the W key
player 1 Y is going to get itself plus
negative paddle speed times Delta time
so it's going to move up it's going to
take negative paddle speed multiply it
by Delta time and add that on to our Y
value which I'll have the effect of
shifting our paddle up and it's the
opposite for on line 82 for if we're
pressing the S key we need to increase
the Y by positive paddle speed because
recall Y axis movement is up is negative
down is positive we're doing the exact
same thing with the paddle on the right
except we're using up and down as the
strings into love keyboard is down and
then down below here we are rendering in
addition to what we rendered before also
the score now so on line 125 note that
we're calling loved graphics set font
score font because if we don't call this
it'll use just whatever the last font
was which by default is the 8 pixel font
because we set that up top
in our program we want to set it to the
score font and then we want to call a
block traffic stop print in this case
I'm just printing them in concrete
places not using printf virtual with / -
- 50 so no matter how we scale our
window it's always going to be 50 pixels
to the left of the center of the window
and the 30 pixels to the right of the
center of the window if we're rendering
the player to score and so if we go into
pong 3 and we run it it looks the same
as before it note we debt we do have
score now in the middle of the screen
zero and zero but more importantly we
can move our paddles up and down but
there's one problem and that's I can
move beyond the edge of the screen which
is not behavior that we want in our
application so we have some
interactivity it's moving along but we
still have a long ways to go
unfortunately or fortunately so let's go
ahead and look at the ball update so we
have paddles they can move they can move
beyond the edge of the screen but we
don't have a ball that it just sits in
the middle of the screen and that's not
what we're looking for we want to have a
ball that we can actually bounce between
the paddles we can get actual game going
beyond just moving paddles so a few
important functions were going to look
at we're going to our first look here at
random so in games random number
generation is a very common thing so
that we get unpredictability and
variability between different instances
of our game an important function that
just belongs to Lua it's not a left to D
thing it's just a Lua thing math dot
random seed num so many of you probably
heard of like a seed like a random
number generators seed and that just
means a random number generator because
it's pseudo-random it needs some sort of
starting value to base all of its random
numbers off of it takes a starting
number it performs some mathematical
operation on that number to derive new
random values that we can then use in
our game engine but if we give it the
same number every single time it's just
going to give us the same random numbers
every single time which means it's not
going to be random at all it's going to
be very consistent so we need a way to
seed our random number generator give it
a different initial value or seed
and we're going to do that with the
function math.random seed some num OS
dot time is an important function in the
context of this because a very common
way of getting a different number every
time you run your application is passing
it in whatever the current time is in
seconds because usually it's a very
large number that is going to be
different every single time you run your
game no matter what because it's based
upon in the context of most engines in
the context of Lua the what's called
UNIX epoch time which is 0 0 UTC January
1st 1970 which is some huge number 9 or
10 digits long
that changes every single second and
then in order to actually take advantage
of all this we need a function to get a
random number and so we do that with
math dot random which takes a min and a
max although you don't need to
technically pass them in it'll just
implicitly do use min as one if you
don't pass it a min and it'll return a
value inclusively within that range so
if we say math dot random 1 comma 50
it'll give us a random inclusively
between 1 and 50 and if we just say math
dot random 50 it'll do the same exact
thing it'll say it'll assume our min is
1 and give us a value between 1 and 50
and then two important mathematical
functions that are very basic but
helpful in the context of games almost
everywhere is just math dot min which
returns the lesser of two values and
math dot max which returns the greater
of two values and we'll see this in the
context of clamping values to some range
so let's go ahead and take a look at a
demo here so I'm gonna go ahead and open
up pong for
and we're going to look at main.lua
therein so here on line 47 we see we're
calling the math dot random seed
function as before and note that we're
passing in OS dot time another function
call
because OS that time is going to be
different every time we run our
application so we're seeding our
application every time we run it based
on whatever the current second is
relative to 0 0 0 0 0 0 January 1st 1970
which is gonna be different every single
time we run assuming you don't run it
within the same second and then if we go
down to line 71 and said are sorry 67
and 68
we now have we're giving a starting
value to our ball because we want to
actually start manipulating our ball so
we give it an X and a Y so we're setting
it right to the center again but now
we're defining a variable for it B
instead of just rendering it statically
with our loved our FX dot rectangle
function because we want this to change
over time and want to start letting our
ball move around the screen so these x
and y variables are going to start
changing now and they're gonna change
relative to its current velocity and its
velocity is gonna be stored in ball DX
and ball dy DX and dy are common
shorthands for Delta X and Delta Y which
is how you represent velocity so what
we're gonna do effectively is take
whatever our Delta X and Delta Y are and
add them onto our ball frame by frame
and that's gonna have the effect of
updating our balls position by some
value and separating the Delta X and the
Delta Y will allow us to have different
angles different trajectories for our
ball and then another thing that we're
also doing in this application we're
starting in the concept of a game state
because now we can have a starting state
and what we're gonna have is a play
state and so all we're gonna do here in
this example in this application is
store our state as a string in future
examples we're gonna use what's called a
state machine and actually separate out
different States into their own into
their own modules but in the context of
this game or is gonna use a simple
string just to illustrate how it works
and we're gonna say our first state when
we start the game should be the start
string in the start state
and so here on line 86 or we're going to
do is solve a problem that we had in the
last example which was the paddles could
move beyond the edges of the screen
which is not behavior that we should
permit so we're gonna call math Bob max
on zero and the same operation we were
doing before and that'll have the effect
of returning whichever those of those
two values is greater so if the value is
if we're adding negative paddle speed to
our Y value and it goes into the
negative range which means it's beyond
the top edge of the screen zero is gonna
be the greater of those values and so
it'll always be zero in that case math
op max returns the greater the two
values so it'll have the effect of
clamping it such that it never goes
above the top edge the inverse is true
for line 96 where we call math dot min
on virtual height minus 20 and player 1
y plus paddle speed delta x delta time
and so let's have the same effect it'll
return whichever of these two values is
lesser in which case if we've gone above
virtual height minus 20 which is down at
the bottom of the screen shifted by the
size of our paddle it's going to set it
to virtual height minus 20 so we never
go below that point and we're doing the
same thing for player two exact same
logic and then if we're in the play
state we're going to actually update our
balls position so we're in the store if
we're in the start state ball is not
going to move at all but if we're in the
play state we want ball X to equal ball
X plus ball x times Delta time and note
that there is no shorthand in Lua for
adding value to itself which is why
we're calling ball x equals ball x plus
bollocks times delta time instead of
just saying ball x plus equals ball x
times delta time just a language
decision that they've made but if we're
in the play state
this will have the effect of scaling
whatever our current balls velocity is
and times delta x so or it stays
framerate independent and then adding it
to ball X and ball Y which will shift it
and we get this actually working down
here in line 170 170 for where now
instead of just rendering flat numbers
to the screen we're actually using ball
X and ball Y to render and if we're in
the play state those will get updated
but if we go back up to line 127 now
we're in the love key pressed function
so we're starting at line 120 before we
just had the if K equals escape then
love dot event not quit but now on line
127 we're going to check to see if the
key is equal to enter or return and then
we're going to use that as our way of
just testing state changes so we're
gonna say if the game state is equal to
the start once you press entered game
state should be equal to play otherwise
set it back to start and we set it back
to start we're gonna reinitialize our
X&Y to be in the center virtual width
divided by 2 minus 2 virtual height my o
divided by 2 minus 2 and we're gonna
give it an initial random starting
velocity again and note here this math
dot random to equal is equal to 1 and
100 or negative 100 is just LOA's way of
doing a ternary operation so and see it
will often have like you would be
something like math.random 2 equals 1
and you would have a question mark 100 :
negative 100 it's the same exact thing
but Lua doesn't have that sort of
shorthand for a ternary operation so we
do it with and and or we use logical
operations instead to do the same thing
and note here we're also showcasing that
math dot random can take either one
argument or two arguments in this case
we're saying math.random 2 which means
it will give us a value between 1 & 2 so
a 50/50 and then if we do negative
fifty-fifty that means we'll get a value
between negative 50 and 50 so a range of
100
effectively and so what that has the
effect of doing if we run our
application we go into pong for we're in
the start state so now we're rendering
if we're in the start state it's set to
render that message if we press ENTER
the ball gets a random velocity applying
the velocity frame-by-frame it's
updating in the update method and press
ENTER again it gets reset and we're back
in the start state so we do it again
it's getting a random value do it again
random value random value so every time
we're getting a different random ball
value but what happens if we try to
actually run it or try to interact with
it nothing go straight through so we're
missing a key piece even though we have
the core components of our game engine
implemented we don't have any concrete
gameplay nothing's interacting and
that's a major piece that we need to
look at and so the next before we
actually start doing that though we're
gonna take a look at the class update
pong 5 and so in order to get into more
of a in order to scale our code more
effectively we need to start looking in
terms of classes and so instead of
having an X and a y for our ball and x
and a y for our paddle a Delta X Delta Y
for our ball all these different
variables that are sort of all over the
place we're going to blow it our code
before we get too crazy with it we
should think about how can we put this
data all together so that we can just
think in terms of our paddles or our
ball object and so we use what's called
a class if unfamiliar a class is simply
a way of taking all these variables that
we've been using thus far but putting
them together in a container such that
we can just say paddle X or paddle you
know in this case car if we have a
function called drive car now we can
just say car drive instead we don't have
to have functions that are separate from
our values that we can put them all
together we can ask what what's our cars
current mileage instead of having all
these different variables all over the
place so classes are effectively
blueprints use it you define a class you
say ok my my car class it's going to
is gonna have a mileage variable it's
gonna have a paint variable is gonna
have a make and a model it's gonna have
all these things and it's gonna maintain
its own state it's gonna maintain all
that for us as seen here then and
typically these are what are called
fields and then we'll have methods as
well functions that instead of being
completely separate from this data a car
now basically owns its own functions it
has its own method called drive or turn
or honk etc and we don't need to have a
function called like turn car or honk
car etc and then this this class is
effectively a blueprint we'll see
shortly how to define a class but in
order to actually have like one paddle
that has its own set of data and another
paddle that has its own set of data we
need to define we need to instantiate
create objects from this class basically
use this class as a blueprint but take
it to a factory and create concrete cars
from the blueprint and those are objects
and so as seen here our paddles and ball
are perfect simple use cases for doing
this so let's go ahead and take a look
at pong five
here so in pong 5 immediately if you
look at the directory structure you can
see that we've added a bald Lua and a
paddled Lua and it's tradition in most
languages that have object-oriented
programming as it's called to capitalize
class names just so you can
differentiate classes for example from
concrete objects or variables or
functions so if you go to our main UI on
line 35 we're requiring a library called
class which is what's going to allow us
to actually create these classes because
classes are not in native they are in a
sense a native Lua feature but LOA's way
of doing object-oriented programming is
a little bit convoluted some folks have
kindly put together a library that makes
it a lot simpler and a lot more closely
related to other languages that do
object-oriented programming more
predominantly like Java or C sharp or
even Python allow us to use the keyword
class in a way that's very similar to
those libraries on line 39 and 43 we're
requiring our own code paddle and ball
and we're going to take a look at those
right now so we can see what a class
looks like so I'm going to go ahead and
open up
a the ball file ball Lua and we can see
here all we need to do just to create a
ball class is using our class library
ball gets class and then curly brackets
like that and so now we have a class
object a class table effectively because
everything in lua is a table but we can
think about it in terms of objects we
have a class object called ball and then
we can start to define functions that
belong to this class so we're gonna
define what's called a constructor or
any NIT function in this case an
initializer that's gonna allow us to
initialize our ball with whatever we
want in this case we want to start our
ball off with an X and a Y and a width
and a height and notice within here we
have a word called self self and this
are common words in object-oriented
programming languages that mean whatever
object we're creating with this class
it's gonna be self so we'll see that in
a we'll see that shortly self dot X gets
X so whatever concrete object we create
using this call this init call set it's
X to this X so that it's Y to the Y set
its width set its height that specific
object self and then we're doing the
same thing for Delta Y and Delta X only
that we're setting those two random
values just as we did before self dy
self dot DX that belongs to whatever
specific object gets instantiated using
this init call as we'll see in the code
we're defining our just a reset function
here just to make it easy before we had
a several lines of code that set our
ball to the middle of the screen and
gave it a random velocity we're doing
that now and this is a good way of sort
of refactoring out groups of logic that
we're creating a function called reset
that just does that all in one function
call and we just call that within our
main function condensing our code and
then notice we have an update and a
render function now and we're gonna call
these from our own update and our own
draw function such that every object
that we want in our game and every
entity and we'll build upon this game by
game in the future we'll just call
update and render on everything from our
main Lua and defer all of that to each
individual class and
objects so we don't have to have a main
Lua that's like 800 lines of code we
just break out all of the updates that
are pertinent to the ball here and all
the render code that's pertinent to the
ball here call each individual balls
update and render and save ourselves a
lot of time and refactoring we're doing
the same thing if we look at paddle
paddles a class as well it gets the it
we're using the class library same exact
sort of thing here XY width height and a
dy in this case we're just initializing
that to zero so that we're not moving
and then we're calling the update
function here so if our dy is less than
zero we're using the math.max function
as before with the top edge of the
screen and then whatever our y plus our
current dy is so Delta Y and then here
self dot y gets math dot min virtual
height minus self dot height self dot y
plus self dot dy times Delta time so
that's the clamping behavior that we saw
before with the paddles only now we took
it from main and we put it in our update
function so each paddle calls its update
and we take some lines of code out of
our main file and then it has its own
render function here same as the paddle
the render function for the paddle and
the render function for the ball are
effectively the same and so if we go to
our main we see we're requiring the
paddle of our powering ball so that we
can use them so if we go down to line 79
instead of initializing our ball DX ball
D Y ball X bar Y paddle Y the player 1y
player 2 Y now we have player 1 is
simply paddle 10 35 20 and player 2 is a
paddle virtual with minus 10 virtual
height minus 35 20 ball is a ball
virtual width divided by 2 minus 2
virtual height minus 2 minus 2 divided
by 2 - 2 4 + 4 so those paddles now have
control over their own X&Y
their own width and height and the
Battle of the ball has its own control
over the X Y width and height that and
the self applies to this object this is
whatever self was in our constructor
that we saw before so each and now we
can just call so we can simply say
player 1
ex-player one dot with player one dot y
and everything is contained we don't
need you know a million variables to
keep track of all the things going on in
our game and this is going to be
especially important as we scale and we
have maybe we have a hundred things on
the screen at one time we don't want 100
times X of variables where X is however
many properties that thing has that we
need to keep track of it's all the same
logic except now we're calling player
one update and player two update in our
update function instead of having all
that logic therein where they're moving
and then keeping track of whether or not
they're going past the top and bottom
edges of the screen and then if game
state is play we're now just calling
ball update and these are all getting
passed in Delta time and then same thing
here it's instead of having all that
logic for resetting the ball as a one
block of code we took it out we
refactored it we put it into our ball
class and now all we have to do is just
one line of code ball reset and then
here down and line 169 in our draw
function we just have player 1 render
player to render ball render and later
on as we scale and we make games that
have a lot more things on the screen a
lot more entities we can just do these
renders in a loop we can just say for
each entity in our screen just render it
for each entity in our screen just
updated we can condense thousands
hundreds of lines of code into just a
few lines of code by deferring update
logic and rendering logic to each
individual entity
thanks to object-oriented programming
and so that's how we're going to
refactor using classes so any questions
on how any of that works so far
cool this is a good point I think to
take a five-minute break and once we
come back we'll talk about how to look
at frames per second alright so we're
gonna take a minute just to look at
something kind of small but often it's
the case we're in games if we want to
make sure that we are performing like
our application is performing well we
want to some way to monitor our frames
per second and so I figured I would just
take a second to illustrate this quickly
so that we can use this in the future
the two functions that are going to be
important for us here well the first of
these is just a little small cosmetic
addition to the application it's just
love window dot set title title so far
our application I'm not entirely sure
what the it says by default I think it
says let's just say untitled yeah so
that's not it's a layer of lack of
polish more or less and it'd be nice
just to solve that problem quickly so
we're gonna call a function called love
window dot set title some string which
will solve that problem quickly we can
make it look as if we have that detail
down and then the thing that's actually
gonna let us determine whether or not we
are running well or we're running very
poorly is a function called love timer
dot get frames per second dot get fps
which is something that love graciously
gives us for free and allows us to very
easily slap it wherever you want can
print it to the console or we can just
draw it straight to our application in
this case we're going to do the latter
so I'm gonna go ahead and go into love
or pong six in our main if we go ahead
and look at line
line 64 loved window set title pong just
quick and easy now our window header is
set appropriately and if we go down to
line 198 here I've decided to sort of
split out this in a separate function
called display FPS on line 198 and the
function is defined on line 207 so a
function display FPS takes no parameters
it's only goal is to just draw our
current FPS to the screen so we're gonna
set our current font to small font we're
going to set our color so this is what I
alluded to before and that we can set
love's rendering color to some RGB a
quadruple and anything that we draw
beyond that point will then be drawn at
it'll be drawn it that whatever that
color is so in this case we're giving it
red of 0 255 on the green 0 blue 255
fully opaque which has the effect of
setting our color to just completely
green and then love graphic stop print
our current fps we're gonna a string and
then our current fps here which is love
timer get FPS but it's gonna return that
as a number and by default Lua does not
allow you to concatenate strings and
numbers so we're going to concatenate
here with this dot dot operator which is
the way of doing string concatenation in
lua we're gonna call the two string
function so we're going to take in love
that timer get FPS we're gonna make it a
string and they're gonna concatenate it
here and then we're gonna call love dot
graphic stop print on that value and
then we're gonna put it at 1010 so
shipped it just a little bit from the
top left edge of the screen so that's
gonna have the effect of the go to pong
six and we run it we can see now it
starts at zero and 52 because it has to
gather a few frames of data before it
has a number we can actually use but we
see there FPS at 60 and so our game runs
otherwise just the same so completely
random a little bit broken but that's
okay well we'll fix it up but currently
we have a problem and
that's that our ball is just going
straight through our paddles so how can
we fix this problem we need some way of
detecting collision so in 2d games
generally
there's a concept of a a BB collision
detection and what this is is axis
aligned bounding box collision detection
which means that we have bounding boxes
just rectangles quads which have an x
and y and a width and a height which are
non rotated so they're completely
aligned with our axes they're completely
parallel perpendicular so the only way
that we can get this easy math the AABB
collision detection working is if we
have no rotation of our boxes they have
to be completely aligned but if they are
we have a very simple algorithm which is
we're just making sure that no edges of
our boxes are outside the opposite edges
of our of the other rectangle so if we
have one rectangle and I'll illustrate
this on the screen here we have two
rectangles if this top edge is below
this edge we know no matter what they're
not going to interest they're not
intersecting there's no way it can
because it's below here so no matter
where it is on the X and the y if it's
below here it's it's not a collision if
this edge is on this side of this
rectangle we know as well there's no way
those two boxes can overlap and it
applies to every edge as long as it is
the opposite edge so if this edge is
below this one if this edge is above
this one if this edge is on the right
and this edge is on the left it means
that no matter what those boxes aren't
colliding so we can simply do four
conditions we can say if rect 1 dot X is
not greater than rec 2 X + rec 2 width
and rect 1 X plus rect 1 dot width is
not less than rec 2 X so if the two
edges are not beyond their opposite
edges same thing with the Y and the y
plus recommend we know
that we have a collision we know that
because we haven't fulfilled any of
those criteria but we know that if
that's not true if if the one of the
edges is not beyond the opposite edge
then it's we do have a collision so it
is gonna be true so we'll see that here
in our code the go to pong 7 at line 113
we have a function that we're calling
called ball collides our ball class has
a function called collides so let's go
ahead and take a look at our ball class
and in this case we've defined our
function such that it takes in a paddle
parameter so it's going to compare
against another rectangle that has an XY
and a width and a height and we're
saying that if our X is greater than the
paddle X plus the paddle width which
means if our X is greater than the right
edge so if our top left is greater than
the or just our left is greater than the
right edge we know that we can't collide
same thing if it's greater than the
other rectangles self X plus self dot
width
oh those sorry the the in that case that
if the paddles X is basically the same
operation but from the paddles
perspective if the paddle is greater
than the rectangle on the right side if
it's farther along the right side past
the right edge we know that there can be
no collision it's just impossible
same thing with Y if the Y self dot Y so
this ball is Y is greater than the
paddles y plus the paddle height so if
it's below the edge of the paddle
because we're taking the the height into
consideration or if the paddles Y is
greater than this
bawls y+ self dot height then we know
that that also can't be a collision but
if that's not true then we need to
return true and so if we go back to our
main hope that's the wrong main go back
to me and aloha here we're calling ball
dot collide so if we're in our game
state if we're in our sorry if we're in
our play state if game state is equal to
play if the ball collides with player 1
so player 1 is the left paddle so if
there's a collision detected the ball DX
and DX is our X velocity so it's
whatever direction it's moving on the x
axis so it's going to be moving to the
left if it's gone if we detected a
collision and it doesn't matter whether
it's moving left or right but we need to
do what we need to do is set it to its
negative value because if it's moving
left and we said let's say it's moving
left and it's negative 20 pixels and we
said 2 20 the DX is now 20 it's gonna
start moving to the right it's gonna
have the effect of inverting its X
velocity and therefore reversing its
direction but what we're also doing here
with x 1.03 is we're multiplying a
little bit just to speed up the game
because we don't want the game to into
perpetuity to just have the same
velocity it's not gonna it's not gonna
ramp with the excitement we want to keep
things going we want to get some
momentum going so what we're gonna do is
call ball DX equals it's negative value
times a scalar that we've determined
arbitrarily in this case I've decided it
should be point one point zero three so
it'll increase it by three percent every
time and then in the event that we have
a our ball mmm because it's getting
added its X velocity is getting added
each frame to its position we want to
make sure that it's not like inside of
our paddle because it's possible that it
could it could shift a certain number of
pixels to the left or to the right
because the same operation applies such
that the two are sort of like on top of
each other we want to read we want to
shift it we want to reset it so what
we're gonna do because it'll detect
another collision immediately
that's the case if it on the next frame
it's within that paddle it's gonna say
that it's it's still colliding with that
paddle so it's gonna shift its velocity
again and that's gonna have the effect
of it infinitely sort of bouncing back
and forth within the paddle we don't
want that to happen
so if it did if we detect a collision we
want to shift it we want to make sure
it's completely outside of the paddles
collision box
so we're saying ball dot X gets player 1
X + 5 + 5 because that's the width of
the paddle so that has the effect of
just once we detect a collision negative
CETIS X velocity - negative and then
instantly shift it right on the right
edge of the left paddle and we're doing
the same thing here if ball collides a
player - we're doing the we're negating
or inverting its X velocity and then
this is the same exact operation but
since it's based on the the left top
left corner we can't - it by five that
it wouldn't make sense we're gonna - it
by four because that's the width of the
ball so if we - it by five we would have
one pixel of space we plussed it by five
on this example because we're coming in
from the right side we want to just make
sure that it's right on the right edge
of the paddle so we're setting it to
player 1 X and in this case we're using
the minus 4 because that's the width of
the ball so we want to shift it to the
left the the width of the ball and that
will have the effect of the right paddle
if there's a collision it'll just get
shifted over and the right the ball will
be touching the paddle right on there 2
edges here on line 118 we're solving the
problem we had before of what happens
when the oh sorry that's actually not
what I was thinking of this is the if
there's a collision then we want the
balls Y velocity to randomize every time
so this has the effect of when we're
playing the game and we've detected a
collision between the two paddles we
don't want the same angle back and forth
every time because then again we'll just
infinitely take place the exact same the
same angle will just keep happening over
and over again we don't want that to
happen we want some variability in terms
of how the ball bounces off the
so what this does is still within the
condition if the ball collides with
player one we're going to say if the the
Y velocity of the ball is negative then
we want to keep it going negative we
still want the ball like if the balls
coming at it sort of an upward angle and
it bounces off the paddle we want the X
velocity to shift we want it to go the
opposite direction but I want the ball
to keep going up we don't want the ball
to like bounce back down which wouldn't
make any sense we don't want to negate
the Y velocity so we're gonna keep the Y
velocity negative we're gonna set it to
a negative value between ten and 150 and
it's just arbitrary you can set it to
whatever you want and then we're gonna
do the same thing if the Y velocity is
positive we want the ball to okay we
want the ball to go in the positive
direction if it's already coming down so
we're doing the exact same thing here
it's the same logic in the player to
instance and then this was what I
thought I was looking at before for a
second but this is how we fix the issue
of the upper and lower boundary of the
screen right because it's one thing to
solve the fact that we have the paddles
now deflecting the ball but we don't
want the ball to infinitely go above the
top edge of the screen or the bottom
edge of the screen so this is just a
simple candle if condition we're just
saying if the ball is less than or equal
to zero which means if the ball is the
top edge of the screen just set it to
zero so make sure it doesn't go above
the edge of the screen and then negate
its Y velocity so it's instantly going
to start going downwards yeah this
question is about pong 7 line 113
couldn't the shifting of the balls DX
and y be done in the ball collides
function if there is a collision the
shifting of the of the balls function if
ball collide no collides the ball the
collides function is a it just returns
true or false so it would be I mean I I
think you probably could refactor it out
that way but the purpose of collides
isn't to have any sort of side effects
like that it's only purpose is just to
return true or false because we can do
any we could have any sort of behavior
we want in a collides function we may
not necessarily want to shift the ball
or do anything much
want to return true and print something
to the console so in terms of I think in
an engineering perspective it makes more
sense just to have a simple true or
false function and then determine how
you want that to actually influence your
game state inside your main function or
inside some other function okay and so
yeah we went down here top edge of the
screen and then bottom edge of the
screen if the ball dot why it's same
exact thing just the bottom edge of the
screen if the ball dot y is greater than
or equal to virtual height minus four
and we're doing virtual height minus
four Y exactly so we want to make sure
that we write as soon as we the bottom
edge of the ball touches the bottom of
the screen we want to detect a collision
then we want to say balled out why the
gets virtual height minus four in case
it overshot the bottom edge based on how
much time is elapsed and how much the
velocity is we want to instantly put it
right up so that it's at the edge so
that it's a clean bounce and then we
want to negate the Y velocity just the
same as we did up above and so if we run
our program here pong seven looks the
same but now the ball is bouncing and
note that it got an egg it got our
random it looks like swimming below the
bottom edge because the monitor is
currently at 720 and that's the window
resolution but it is bouncing off the
bottom edge as well and the angle if you
note is a little bit different every
time because we are giving it a random Y
velocity Y yeah then that's influencing
oh I messed up I wanted to illustrate
the the speed increase it's gonna take a
little bit of time but every time it
detects a collision it is going to be
scaling it's the X velocity by one point
zero three so it's going to make it a
little bit faster and I'm currently the
Y angles a bit steep so it's going to
take forever to illustrate that but
we'll see that in a later example so
we have the basics of our game
but how are we keeping score what's the
determining factor for how we keep score
and pong left to right as long as it
goes past the left or right edge of the
screen so what do we need to dare by do
we do need a counter and we need to also
monitor whether the ball has collided
with the left or the right boundary of
the screen and then have that increment
that counter so we're going to go ahead
and take a look at pong 8 to see how
this is implemented we have here on line
88 and 89 some counter variables player
1 score player to score we've had those
for a long time but we haven't used them
we've only used them to draw to the
screen we're actually going to now
increment them and show them as
scorekeeping variables in our code here
I thought I had implemented it in pong 8
but I think I might have left out the
actual incrementing of the score but
this is the logic that's pertinent to
that example so if ball X is less than 0
which just means if we've gone past the
left edge of the screen
ignore serving player for now the
important thing is now we are doing
player to score gets player to score +1
just a simple increment and then we're
resetting the ball same thing for here
if the ball dot X is greater than
virtual width so past the right edge of
the screen and it actually could be
virtuous ball X plus 4 is greater than
virtual width then and it will have the
same effect but actually no because we
want to make sure that we don't see the
ball at all when they when they score so
yeah this is actually correct if ball
dot X is greater than virtual width then
serving player gets to player 1 score is
player 1 square plus 1 and then we're
gonna reset the ball serving player so
now what we need to talk about is the
idea of serving so when we start up the
game so let's go ahead and take a look
at
we're gonna go to pong nice so we're
gonna go straight to pong 9 and then we
need to take a look at what a state
machine is so currently in the game
we've talked about state a little bit
we've had this the start state which
means the game is ready for us to just
press enter and then the ball will go
off in a random direction and then we
have the place date and a place date is
set to our paddles interacting with the
ball and then keeping track of score
basically a state machine is very
important it's a ubiquitous concept in
game development
it just means how can we monitor what
state we're in and what transitions take
place between those states to bring out
new states and each individual state has
its own logic and by breaking out the
logic of these states separately we can
scale our code much bigger and not have
monolithic code for and this this
particular diagram is an example of what
you might have as a state machine for a
character like Mario where you have a
ducking state a release state which
takes the doubt the in black the input
of down so if we releasing down he'll
become standing so ducking state the
transition is release the down key he
becomes standing standing key press the
down key he becomes ducking these are
states and transitions these individual
states are the overall representation of
his behavior at large basically and the
same logic applies to our game we have a
play state we have a serve state we want
to have maybe a game over state if
someone scores 10 points then it should
say oh the winner is X and you can
define any arbitrary number of states
that which depends upon your model
whatever game you want to develop for
example like Super Mario has a title
screen maybe your game has a like a high
score state you want to display all the
high scores in your game and will
actually show that in a lecture next
week but this is the this is what a
state machine is it's just a it can be
in any one particular state at one time
and the transitions are what allow you
to go in between your states and each
state does have transitions in and out
of other states and we're going to use
this
in pong 9 so beyond illustrating the
score we are going to start keeping
track of more than just the start and
the play state we're actually going to
start modeling the serve state and so
let me go ahead and illustrate what this
looks like so if we're here I just
pressed entered we started at the start
state as normal but I pressed enter and
now it says player 1 serve so we're
actually serving and so if I press enter
again as it instructs me player ones on
the left the ball should move to the
right which it does so I'm gonna go
ahead and lose on purpose as player 2
and now it's player to serve so
whichever character whichever player
loses should get to serve again and so
now if I press Enter note when we were
player 1 the ball moved to the right so
if your player to the ball moves to the
left so we have now a little bit more
interaction we have different states we
start off the game and then we serve and
we play so when we're when the ball is
live when we're actually doing this
we're in the play state now in the serve
state so what's the transition between
the sort of the this the play state and
the serve state what's the transition
there we score a point so if we if we if
we're looking at our state diagram and
we're in the play state the transition
to the serve state is X player scores a
point and then if we're in the serve
state the transition is someone presses
enter Enter key gets pressed and so
that's how we want to think about our
games if we have a bunch of different
sets of sort of logic that we can sort
of exhorting out of our game and think
about conceptually it allows us to break
our game up into a bunch of different
modes and States and not really get
overburdened by all these variables that
maybe need to keep track of or what what
state are we in like what are all these
variables doing and we'll see how we can
break this out in a more modular fashion
in future weeks
note that right now currently all we're
doing is we're setting a state variable
to some string here and just doing if
conditions on it which works
fantastically for small examples so if
like for example if we're in the update
function and game states see if we're
here we're saying if the game state is
set to serve then we're initializing all
of the variables if the game state is
play then we need to actually perform
our logic here so if the if we're in
play this is going to get called each
frame and we're gonna say if ball
collides with player 1 do all this stuff
and then this allows us to sort of think
of our game it's almost like having
separate update functions within our
update function and we'll actually see
how we can take these out of one update
function in future weeks with a actual
state machine class and implement things
a little bit more abstract Li but
suffice to say now whenever we wanted
like for example to make a transition
if someone scores here like if we're
going to the left side of the screen if
ball dot X is less than 0 all we have to
do is just set this state to serve and
our update function is then going to
update appropriately so any questions on
how sort of state machines or the state
works here in the context of palm yes
the same machine is sort of a the
overall conceptual look at what your
different states are and their
transitions yes and in future weeks
we're not implementing a state machine
object or a class here but in future
weeks we will see a state machine class
that manages transitions between
different states in a more modular and
clean fashion while all we're doing here
is our state machine is just if
statements and saying if the state is
equal to this then do this and then
change the state to some value it is a
concept yeah but we will see an
implementation of a state machine as an
object next week any more questions
okay cool so currently we have scoring
as we saw the player one scorer and
player to score are getting incremented
now and therefore getting rendered to
the screen whenever we go to the left or
the right edge so we're keeping track of
score but what do we need now in order
for someone to win sorry yes it does
exactly so it's actually quite simple
all we need to really do is just an if
statement right if someone's score is
equal to some value 10 then some player
is 1 so if we look at player if you look
at pong 10 we go to main and go to
here line 174 and also align 160 we can
see that all it literally is is in our
logic from before where we're just
testing to see whether the ball is gone
beyond the left of the right edge
because this is effectively where you
need to do your check anyway to see
whether someone scored a point so all
we're doing is adding logic to that part
of the program and saying after we
increment their score if it's equal to
10 we're setting a value called winning
player we're gonna set it to two
so if the ball dot x is less than zero
then that means that player 1 got scored
on because it went past the left edge of
the screen there for a player to score
should go up and therefore the winning
player should be 2 if the player to to
score is equal to 10 and in this case he
were here we're setting a new state done
and then if that's not the case so if
their score is still less than 10 we
should still we should set it back to
serve and then reset the ball and so if
you go to our update function here
actually we're doing it in our our
update phase so currently if the if the
if it's the done state the ball gets
reset but no update is being applied to
the ball in that case we still have
scores 10 it'll still render the score
so score whoever's got 10 and we'll show
the other player score and the actual
logic that applies here whenever we want
to break out of that state is in our
loved key pressed key function we see
your online 227 if game state is equal
to done which we've set it to before and
this will only execute if they've
pressed enter or return so it's
effectively waiting for them to press
Enter or return
we want to set game state back to serve
we want to reset the ball we want to
initialize their scores back to 0 so
we're setting up we're a brand new game
effectively if the winning player is 1
then we'll give serving player 2 to so
that they have the advantage on the on
the next game and then otherwise set it
to 1 and if we go down to our render
function so down to line 275 if we're in
the
state then we should render to the
screen player and then winning player
because remember we set winning player
to one or two depending on whether
depending on who won bin ago who scored
that the tenth point will say player one
or two wins and we'll just render that
and then press ENTER to restart after
that and that's the logic for that and
we can see this in play also if it's a
if it's too slow we might not have to go
through an entire run but I sped up the
whoops opponent you want to actually hit
the ball back I set up the speed so it's
we're in the surf State we're in the
play state it's up the ball bounce back
it's gonna be a bit tedious but it slice
to say it's a big payoff
don't worry should have set the speed a
little faster almost there it's getting
tense and player one wins so there we're
also setting the font to a larger size
and in the in the code I create a new
font object that's basically between the
small font and the score file which is a
large font so 16 size font and so player
1 wins and that's that's really all it
boils down to just keeping track of your
counter and just making sure that when
you do hit 10 in your logic for
detecting the the screen collisions that
you set the state to done and if the
state is done then you just need to
monitor keyboard input and see whenever
someone presses enter so one press enter
and our lucky pressed it does the it has
the effect of setting player its player
to serve because player 1 1 so it's only
fair we're gonna press ENTER to serve
and then we begin a brand new game and
that's simple so now we have an
infinitely playable game with a bunch of
simple states we're missing a very
important detail though in my opinion
and that sound currently our game is
just very it's it's it's great the
gameplay all works everything is working
fine but it's just missing a little
little polish and so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna start adding audio to the
game which is in my opinion one of the
more fun things to add because also
means you're close to the end of your
project loved audio new source is a
function we're gonna look at here all
this is going to do is take a path and
then optionally a type
and this path is going to be to a sound
file and it's going to create an audio
object that you can play back at any
point in your application so what we're
gonna effectively do is just whenever a
collision happens depending on what type
of collisions is we'll just play a
particular sound and a program that I
really like to use for all of this and I
what I encourage you guys to download if
you want to start tinkering with your
own sounds for your project is a program
called BFX err it's free on Windows and
Mac I'm not sure if they have a Linux
port they might have a Linux port of a
similar program called SFX er which is
what this is based off of but what this
allows you to do is just generate a
bunch of random sounds and I can I can
illustrate that shortly for you if you
would like to grab it it's on B FX or
dotnet it's a super quick download and
they're all actually I'll demonstrate it
just so we can see how it plays out so
this is the interface make sure I have
some audio and then there's a lot of
different presets here so there's pickup
slash coin
Laser slash shoot it's meant for sort of
like small games like this like
implementing on the flies prototype
audio type stuff but you can see it just
implements I'll turn that down a little
ow it we have power-ups for example so
every time I click on this it's gonna
give us a random powerup so
and then randomize you get all sorts of
weird nasty stuff and then the stuff
that will use his blip slash select most
of the things in our in like interfaces
and games like pong you just want simple
sounds like this so I've already done
the work of generating a few sounds that
I thought fit pretty well I'll go ahead
and show you the code first in pong 11
if we go to if you'll see if you look at
the directory structure you'll see we
have a sounds folder in the sounds
folder I've created three sounds paddle
hit which is any time the paddle hits
the ball score which is when any to any
time the ball goes past the left or the
right boundary of the screen and then
wall hit so any time the ball touches
the top or the bottom of the screen and
so the logic of this is extremely simple
all we need to do is whenever we already
have it implemented so all we need to do
is OH
first thing I should say and this is a
this is a good illustration of a table
and we'll start to see this a lot more
in the future we didn't really use
tables much in this lecture but the
table is Lewis like sort of
be-all-end-all data structure it's the
dictionary Python dictionary Java Script
object it's an it's an array it's
everything that you need for anything
beyond simple variables in lua it's what
everything even like classes and other
libraries are made out of in this case
we're just initializing a table here
called sounds and we're passing in three
keys so it takes it can take in key
value pairs or you can just give it a
list of values and it'll create indices
for them implicitly here we're just
passing in like you would do in Python
or JavaScript paddle hit and note that
it does need these square brackets in
order to initialize key value pairs in
the table in this format here paddle hit
gets love audio news source and in this
case it just takes in a path so sound
slash paddle hit wave and we're giving
it the keyword or the the string static
which is the type of asset it is it's
stored as so you can have either static
or stream audio assets
so if they're static they're loaded into
memory and they're kept in memory for
the execution of your program if there's
stream then they're loaded on the fly as
needed by your game engine and streamed
audio assets can be helpful if you have
a huge game with a ton of sounds and
long like large audio files you don't
want to keep all those in memory
necessarily because I could take up many
many many Meg's or gigs of audio and if
you're sort of loading assets on the fly
if you have dynamic loading in your game
then that's another thing you should
take into consideration in this case
these are very tiny sound files because
they're like like a fraction of a second
long so we're just setting them all to
static so that they get preserved in
memory and we're just loading all three
of them into this table and if we want
to refer to these later on all we need
to do is sounds we can either reference
sounds dot paddle hit like that if we
wanted to because by default Lua just
gives you a dot keyword sort of the way
Java Script does it's objects with the
same name as the key that you passed in
or you can do it the pythonic way which
is without the dot sorry with just
square brackets and now have the same
those two are equivalent
it won't work though if you decide to
put a space in your key it will I
believe it'll just won't work at all but
it may inject a and underscore I'll have
to test it out and find out but
generally it's not best practice to use
dot when you already have the keys lined
up like this anyway and what you can do
with strings that you can't do with dot
using the dot notation is dynamically
generate a lookup of your table with you
which you can do with strings which you
yeah because you can't in a for loop do
for something in table and then table
dot something that just won't work but
you can do for everything in your table
and then look up the the key as that
value that iterated value in your table
and we'll see examples of that in future
lectures but something to keep in mind
so we have our table here a sounds table
on and we have our sounds ready they're
loaded in memory all we need to do now
is we're
ever we have anything that like any
collision in our code we just do this
it's as simple as the table at the key
that we want : which is Lewis way of
calling a function of a class or a table
: play and the play function is part of
the new source audio object and love
that we created in the table and that'll
just have the effect of just playing it
once you can set it to looping you can
say the sounds paddle hit set looping to
true and it'll just infinitely play it
over and over again which we wouldn't
want for a sound like this so it's not
obnoxious but if you have a music track
for example in a level or something like
that you would want set looping to be
true so that when it finally ends your
user isn't just playing a game in
silence so we're doing it with paddle
hit we're doing it with wall hit as well
so I've named them appropriately so that
it's easy to infer where and for what
purpose the sound files are used so
whenever they're at the upper lower
boundaries play the wall hit sound and
then whenever the ball reaches the left
or the right edge of the screen just
play the score sound effect and so if we
play our game and this is always one of
my more favorite parts is playing the
game with audio because it just makes
such a difference in my opinion we get
it sound effects it's a little thing and
it's very easy but it adds adds so much
flavor and then and there we go and then
our game is practically implemented at
this point there's just one more example
that I would like to show you guys a
small example because all of the
examples thus far have had the resize
equal resizable equals false sort of key
in the push setup screen initializer and
in case you want to have a game where
you can resize your window all we need
to do is call function called love
resize which takes it width and a height
and what we're going to end up doing
with that specifically for our use case
because we're using push we're gonna go
to pong 12 and then if we go to Main
Laura
we see here and line eighty-five I've
changed resizable to equal true now so
that it'll actually allow us to resize
the application if that's false you
won't even be able to click and drag the
bottom corner of the screen it just
won't let you do it and then I all you
have to do is call love dot resize with
height and then pass in push resize with
height because push underneath the hood
takes a texture and renders to it and
then up scaled it to fill your window
and so it needs to know what your
current window dimensions are so that it
can upscale it to fit the right
dimensions and push also adds things
like letterboxing which is convenient if
you want to maintain the exact same
aspect ratio and in a game where maybe
you have a UI that's driven by the size
of your application this function will
be important because then you can resize
or you can resize and reposition your UI
elements appropriately because if your
game is small maybe you want certain
parts of UI to be invisible or in a
different location all together just so
that you don't take up a ton of screen
space and just to accommodate all
possible users of your application but
that has the effect now of if we go into
pong 12 and then run it actually might
even I be able to use the but yeah I can
just do this now I can resize it and
it'll it'll maintain the the virtual
width and height that we set it to
before because that's like first and
foremost what push will do and in a
letterbox no matter what size your
application is to make sure that it
maintains that aspect ratio so if you're
beyond that aspect ratio vertically or
horizontally you'll get the appropriate
letterboxing for it so it's super
convenient you don't have to worry about
your users getting super distorted
aspect ratios because they're using some
sort of unforeseen resolution it'll
always maintain it even if it's super
tiny because their monitor is super thin
it'll always maintain an aspect ratio
but that's that's pretty much it for
pong actually we have a complete game
start to finish and if you have any
questions would be happy to answer them
any questions cool all right well I'm
excited to teach the rest this course
with you guys we've only scratched the
surface we have a lot more to cover next
week will actually be covering flappy
bird so we'll get some nice colorful
graphics it's just a stark difference to
our black and white aesthetics today but
that's it for pong so thanks for coming